and hi to everyone watching this
presentation
my presentation is about collecting
experimental data from research animals
directly in their home pages
by using automated versions of operative
tests that they get to engage with on a
voluntary basis
i'm going to focus on why and how we
should integrate these types of tests
into biomedical research especially and
particularly in mice because of how
widely used this species is
so here's a quick outline of how this
presentation will unfold
i'm going to start off by telling you
why i think you should care
which is that animal models in
biomedical research currently aren't
really producing results that
carry over into human patients as
readily as we'd like them to
and i'm hoping to convince you that part
of the solution to make these results
more applicable to humans
is to treat research animals more like
we treat human patients
and among other things that means making
their well-being a top priority
i hope to show you that in general this
is beneficial not just for the animals
but for the quality of the science
itself
i'll then go into detail on the role and
potential benefits of one very specific
aspect of treating animals like humans
which is collecting data from them
voluntarily in their home cages instead
of forcing them to participate in
standard hand-drawn tests that they
might find aversive
in various ways so here's here's the big
problem that we're trying to deal with
out of all the experimental drugs that
are tested in human clinical trials
only 11 of them succeed in making it to
market
one reason for 89 of them failing is
that sometimes there's unexpected side
effects
but most of the time it's because they
just don't work
and that's pretty mind-blowing because
all of these drugs were first tested in
animals
and they worked that's why they ended up
being tested in humans
and the ethical consequences of this are
pretty horrifying because it means that
too many animals are being used in
experiments that usually induce some
sort of suffering
and then there's not enough benefit
coming back in the form of effective
treatments being developed for human
patients who are also of course
suffering
so what's going on why don't these
treatments work in the in the humans if
they worked in the animals
i think a big part of that reason is
that preclinical research on animals
is often done very differently from
clinical research on human patients
this includes how the experiments are
analyzed and designed
and it includes how the human and animal
patients are treated throughout the
course of the experiment
and how the outcomes of the experiment
are measured
to put it more bluntly i think it's
often the case the human
and the animal researchers are using
different goal posts or different ways
of determining
whether a drug works or not and so it's
not surprising that they sometimes get
different answers
and these are issues that we explored in
a review paper that we published last
year in the journal lab animal
and of course we're not the only ones
there are many many many other authors
who've discussed these issues along with
some potential solutions and i'm just
showing you a very small selection of
these papers here
now in this presentation i'm going to
focus primarily on the issue of trying
to treat animals
humanely in the same way that we treat
human patients
and i'll focus on how this can affect
the quality of the science so let's
start with a few examples
here's some data from an experiment on
self-administration of analgesic drugs
or painkillers in mice female mice
were subjected to an experimental
surgery and then they were allowed to
self-medicate to relieve their own pain
they had two bottles in their home cage
one of them containing water
and the other one containing ibuprofen
and ibuprofen
ibuprofen intake increased over the two
weeks following surgery in the operated
mice
which is exactly what you'd expect if
they're in pain and if the ibuprofen is
relieving that pain effectively
but here's the crucial twist the mice
were housed in one of four different
conditions
they were either housed in groups of
three or by themselves
and they were either housed in bearing
cages that contained only wood chip
bedding on the bottom of the cage
or they were housed in environmentally
enriched cages that also contained
material to build a nest
and some wooden chewing sticks and it
turned out that the mice consumed less
of the analgesic if they were housed in
grooves
and if they were housed in enriched
cages
so what this shows is that the social
and physical environment of these mice
affected how severe their pain was and
how much pain relief they felt that they
needed
i'll show you another example to show
that this isn't just something that's
going on in their heads
here's an example where the housing
environment actually has very real
tangible physical consequences on health
here hamsters were housed either alone
or with one of their siblings
and they were given a small wound on
their backs using a punch biopsy
and starting on the day after the wound
was inflicted one half of the hamsters
who were pair housed and one half of the
single house hamsters were restrained in
a small tube and they were held there
for two hours every day
this is called the chronic restraint
stress procedure
in all of the hamsters in all the
conditions the wounds healed over time
but there was one group that healed more
slowly than the others
and that's the hamsters who were
subjected to the daily restraints that
stress
and who had who were housed by
themselves
and the authors actually did a separate
experiment to work out the mechanisms
behind this
they got another group of hamsters and
they housed them either alone or in
pairs
and they measured how much cortisol
these animals produced when they were
restrained in the tube cortisol is a
hormone that secreted in stressful
situations
and so correspondingly being restrained
in the tube did cause temporary spikes
in cortisol production
but these spikes only happened in the
socially isolated animals
so being housed with a social partner
actually seems to have been enough to
buffer the animals against the
physiological consequences of that
restraint stress
and against the negative impacts of it
on wound healing
here's one more example of how housing
quality can have
dramatic impacts on animal health this
research was done on scrog dolly rats
who are an outright genetic stalker
stock of rats
that are often used in breast cancer
research because they actually
spontaneously develop
mammary tumors in this experiment the
rats were housed either in groups of
five in a large cage
or alone in small cages
and when they were 15 months of age they
were checked for tumors
and the rats were health in isolation
had developed a larger total tumor
burden
and they had more malignant tumors than
group house rats
two months before this tumor check the
researchers had actually assessed
the physiological stress response of
each rat by restraining them just like
the hamsters
except they only tested it once and just
like in the hamsters the isolated rats
had more severe stress responses than
the group housed rats
and the researchers are actually able to
show that the magnitude of the
stress response was what predicted the
development of tumors a few months after
that test
so this shows again one more time that
social contact which is
good for welfare in a social species
also helps protect the animals from
environmental stressors
and from the effects that these
stressors have on their health
there's a direct parallel to this rat
research in humans
this is data from a paper where
researchers tracked almost 3
000 women who had breast cancer and they
asked these women about their social
networks their social connections
how many relatives do you have how many
friends
do you participate in community or
church groups and based on all of these
responses they classified the women on a
spectrum
from being either socially integrated or
being socially isolated or
somewhere in between and the women who
were rated as socially isolated
actually died of their cancers at rates
twice as high as the socially integrated
women
women who said they had no friends were
four times as likely to die of their
cancer
and it was similar effects for whether
or not they had close relatives
so just as in the rodents we see that
there's tremendous importance of social
support
in determining health outcomes
there's another important thing to note
about this study if you look at the
numbers below each column
n equals that's the number of women in
each of these categories
you can see that there weren't that many
women in the socially isolated
highest risk group they were less than
10 of the entire sample
and far larger numbers of women were
well socially integrated
and so that shows one way in which
treating animals humanely isn't
just about improving their welfare and
it's not even just about improving their
health
it's really also about making them more
like the humans that they're being used
as
models of because most human patients
can count on some measure of support
from their loved ones
and to model this as faithfully as
possible in rodents the right approach
is probably also to usually allow them
to have
some sort of social contact and social
social support in experiments
and there's another way in which
worrying about the welfare of research
animals
is also really about making sure that
they're good models of human patients
so i just showed you several examples
where environmental enrichment given to
lab rodents improve their health
outcomes
these are enrichments like social
companionship or nesting material
but we can ask ourselves what it is
exactly about these enrichments
that does this or what do these
enrichments do for the animal's welfare
a big part of what they do is that they
let the animals control their
environments
control their environments in a way that
protects them from stressors in the
environment
social companions for example provide
support that buffers against
stressors like the restraint stress
procedure that was imposed by
experimenters
and that's also in a way what nesting
material does
if you think about how mice live
in a lab the ambient temperatures at
which we house mice
are actually several degrees below their
thermo-neutral zone
and what that means is that if they
don't have a nesting material they're
chronically cold stressed
in these environments but with nesting
material they can use their behavior to
create a little micro environment around
themselves
a nest which retains their body heat and
keeps them comfortable
and when you think about it that's
exactly what we do with humans too
so i'm sitting in this office right now
and the thermostat is set
several degrees below my thermoneutral
zone and i'm fine
because i put on clothing this morning i
used my behavior
to create a nice little snug micro
environment that i carry around with me
and so the humans and mice are both made
to control their environments
using their behavior to cope with
stressors using their behavior
and so giving animals what they need to
use that behavior
to control their environment as they
want to is not just important for their
welfare
but it's also an important way of
treating them like humans who typically
do have these opportunities and so
potentially
this is also a way of making results of
animal research more applicable to human
patients
so what i've talked so far what i've
talked about so far is
how we house research animals and how we
can do that in a way that treats them
more like we treat humans
i've talked about how this might impact
the validity of preclinical research
now i'm going to turn to how we treat
animals in the moments when we're
running tests on them
but what i mean by this is how do we
treat them outside of the
let's say 23 hours a day when they're
just sitting in their home cage
how do we treat them when we take them
out to actually run tests or to take
measurements
think it turns out there's something
fundamentally different about
the context in which we usually test
humans and the context in which we
usually test
animals and what's different is that
humans participate in studies
voluntarily
they sign consent form and they can
choose not to participate if they don't
want to
but animals are coerced into taking part
in studies
and for a mouse when it's time to run
tests or to take measurements
what being coerced usually means is
being picked up by an experimenter who
by the way looks and smells like a
predator to them
and then being moved out of your home
cage into some sort of testing apparatus
and these are all things that we know
are aversive to mice and
there's actually good evidence that
these aversive parts of the procedure
can have some pretty dramatic impacts on
the outcomes that we measure
here's some data from the mogill lab at
mcgill university
they work on pain and nociception in
mice and one of the standard tests
that they use is the tail immersion test
you take a mouse's tail and you
this one refuses to dip but you dip the
mess of steel into hot water
and then you measure how long it takes
for the mouse to withdraw that fail
and what they did in this study was that
they pulled together data from over 8
000 mice
that they had tested over years and
years to evaluate all the potential
factors that could affect
how quickly mice withdraw their tails
and they found that nearly half of the
variance in the outcomes which is
huge could be explained by the
environment of the test
the most important part of that
environment was the identity of the
tester
the mice consistently take longer to
withdraw their tails from hot water
when they're tested by certain specific
human individuals
in fact the identity of the tester was
the single most predictive factor
in determining that outcome and this is
true even though all the testers were
working in the same lab
with the same equipment and with the
same protocol
the most amazing part of this is that
the identity of the tester actually had
a larger effect than the genotypes of
the mice did
now you have to understand in this line
of research that's usually what
experimenters are trying to determine
do mice with different genotypes have
different phenotypes
do genetic differences explain
behavioral differences
but what these researchers showed is
that who tests the animals actually
introduces a huge amount of variation or
noise into the data
that could potentially drown out any of
the genetic effects that they're looking
for
it seems like there might be an obvious
solution to this
if you're running this lab you'll
standardize the test
you'll say let's have the same person
test all of the mice
but the problem actually runs deeper
than that and that's because
individual testers don't have uniform
effects on all the mice
the effects of each tester actually
depend on the genotype of the mice
to put it differently the effect of the
mouse's genotype
depends on who the tester is and that's
what's called
a genotype by environment interaction
here what we mean by environment is the
person who's doing the testing
and we can see in this example here a
genotype by environment interaction
if you look at the person labeled sw the
author sonia wilson
she tested hundreds of mice and after
doing this she found that dba 2j
mice the middle bar withdraw their tails
faster than aj mice
the right most part but then there's
also the person labeled jm that's
jeffrey mogul
the head of the lab and he also tested
hundreds of mice
and he found no difference if anything
the difference might be reversed
and in later research the same lab
actually found that
mice find the smell of men more aversive
than the smell of
women and so being tested by a male
experimenter causes something called
stress-induced analgesia
which might be part of the reason why
jeffrey's mice leave their tails
in the hot water longer than sony's mice
so this is a pretty dramatic example
where
an experiment actually gives you
completely different answers
according to something that seems so
inconsequential as who the person
handling
testing the mice is and potentially how
aversive they find being handled by that
person
here's one more example of a genotype by
environment interaction in mouse testing
these are the results of a spatial
memory test called the barnes maze
if you're familiar with the morris water
maze the barns maze is basically the dry
version of it
so mice are placed inside of a round
arena that has
many holes in the floor and their task
is to find the correct hole that gets
them a reward
and after performing this test multiple
times they learn to navigate to the
correct hole more and more quickly
now these experimenters here ran two
different versions of the barnes maze
the first one was negatively reinforced
there were fans blowing air
inside the arena during the test my
spine is subversive to have
air being blown over them and so the
reward was that when they found the
correct hole that hole let the mice
escape from the testing arena
and in this test the researchers found
very very clear differences between the
strains
the dba mice in white were much slower
to learn the task than c57 mice
but the second version of the test was
identical except that there weren't any
fans blowing here in the arena
and the test was positively reinforced
the reward for finding the correct hole
was food and in this case there was
absolutely no difference between the
strands
they both learned just as rapidly as the
c57s in the first experiment
so like in the mogil
experiment that i talked about before
this is a case where your conclusion
about which mice are in this case the
best spatial learners
depends on how aversive the testing
environment is
the dba mice in particular were
negatively impacted by aversive testing
conditions
and that's actually an example of what's
known as the yerkes johnson law
this is a behavioral law that stems from
experiments done in the 1930s
in these experiments yorkies and dotson
tested rodents
and how quickly they would learn to
perform a wide range of different
operant responses
in order to avoid getting electric
shocks
and what they both found was that
stronger shocks were more motivating
they made animals learn more quickly
which makes sense
but that was true only up to a certain
point
in the case of cognitive tasks that were
actually complex that were difficult
to learn performance actually started
degrading when the shocks became too
severe
and so that's shown by that rising and
then falling curve at the bottom of that
graph
and the general law that came out of
this work and that's actually been
observed
on many occasions since then is that for
difficult cognitive tasks
performance is poor when arousal is very
low when motivation is low
but performance is also poor when
arousal becomes too high
because the individual is then under
some considerable stress
so we've seen in this section that the
stress associated with testing can alter
experimental results
it can affect something basic like how
quickly reflexes kick in to make a mouse
pull their tails out of the water and it
can affect more complex outcomes like
performance on a difficult cognitive
task
try to keep this in mind as i move
through the rest of the talk because i'm
going to be focusing specifically now on
tests of learning and memory and because
i'll be talking about using automated
home cage versions of these tests
and one of the primary goals of this is
to reduce or to eliminate the aversive
context
that's associated with the conventional
hand run test
in other words the goal or one of the
goals of these approaches
is to give animals control over testing
and measurement so that they engage with
the apparatus voluntarily
when they want to just like human
subjects
so to start this section um
what is it really about a standard hand
run operand test that's so aversive to a
mouse
well first there's being handled by a
predator like experimenter which we
talked about a little bit already second
there's the fact that the arena or the
chamber in which the mouse is being
tested can also be reversible on its own
this can be true even if there's not a
fan blowing air like in the barnes maze
experiment
mice are neophobic by nature which means
that an environment can be aversive to
them
just because it's novel or unfamiliar
and getting over that can require some
pretty considerable work in terms of
habituating a mouse to a new environment
the third problem is that mice are often
socially separated from their companions
during a test
and we saw earlier that social support
can be very important in helping
animals cope with other types of
stressors
finally mice are often food deprived
before taking the test
and that's done to make sure that
they're actually motivated to work for
food during the test
so if we consider these different types
of potential problems with hand-drawn
tests how do we go about
alleviating them making test
environments less aversive
let's start with handling it's start to
ask whether it's even possible to handle
mice in a way that they don't find
aversive
they might just be intrinsically
terrified of us well i'll show you the
typical way to
handle masses to pick the mouse up by
the tail
i read a few papers where researchers
tried habituating mice to this
so that they'd find handling less
aversive by the time they're tested
but these habituation procedures usually
take a very long time
and they have mixed success
but jane hurst and her colleagues did
something different
they exploited the fact that mice will
instinctively run into a shelter in the
presence of a perceived predator like a
human
so what they do is they put a tunnel
into the mouse's home cage like a flexi
glass tub not an actual cupped hat
and then the mouse will run straight
into the tunnel to hide
and then the experimenter can pick up
this tunnel and after a relatively brief
period of gradual training where the
tunnel is brought further and further
away from the home cage
mice will voluntarily run into the
tunnel when a human comes in to handle
them
and in preference tests mice have
actually shown that they prefer this
mice were used to being handled in a
tunnel will voluntarily interact with
the human's hand
and they'll interact with the tunnel
mice who are used to being handled by
the tail will avoid the hand
no tunnel handled mice even allow humans
to scruff them like this
and they continue to volunteer to be
handled even after this happens
mice can also be trained to jump or walk
onto a cut hand
of the experimenter and then be carried
while standing on the hand
and they'll also voluntarily interact
with the experimenter's hand while
tail handled mice will not notice again
that this is an issue of whether or not
the mice have control over stressors in
their environment
being grabbed by the tail is something
that's outside of their control
but if the experimenter is instead
asking them to walk into a tunnel or
jump onto their hand when they're ready
that really does put them in control of
what might otherwise be a much more
aggressive experience
a nursing company actually showed that
these handling techniques can affect the
quality of data
here's an odor recognition test that
they performed on mice handled in
different ways
what happens in this test is that a
mouse is put into a box that contains a
cotton pad
which has urine from a male mouse on it
they then measure how long the female
spends
sniffing this urine when they repeat
this test over three days with the same
male's urine
what they expect to see is what you see
in the habituation part of this graph
the light blue
that she recognizes and remembers this
particular smell and so she spends less
and less time sniffing it from day to
day
then on the very last day this cotton
pad is replaced with one that contains
urine from a different male
so what happens then or what we expect
to see is that the female dish
habituates
and she starts sniffing the cotton pad
again and this shows that she knows that
the two
urines are different
and that's exactly what they found in
mice who are handled using a tunnel in
the non-aversive way
but in my sewer handled by the tail
which remember is the standard method of
doing this
we don't see habituation and we don't
see this habituation
and it looks like that graph is empty
but that's actually what it should look
like
because what the graph shows is the
median response for each trial in the
odor recognition test
and for every trial that median response
was zero seconds spent sniffing the
cotton pad
which means that tail handling had such
a large inhibitory effect on exploration
of that apparatus that
most of the mice just never engage with
the test stimulus at all
in case that's not obvious that kind of
ruins this test
so handling mice using a tunnel is
one way that we can make measurements
less aversive and potentially improve
the quality of these measures
but if the animals are picked up using a
tunnel just so that they can be
transferred into an operant chamber
the other problems remain they might
still be socially isolated they might be
still
tested in a strange environment
so the other solution which also avoids
aversive handling
is to test mice directly in their home
cage and that simultaneously
tackles some of these other problems and
as it turns out that also solves the
food deprivation problem
animals don't have to be food deprived
to maintain motivation because they
actually decide for themselves
when they'll engage with the test in
their home cage generally they won't do
it if they're not
hungry and motivated for the reward
but let's quickly take a look at why
motivation can be less than optimal in
standard hand run tests
first of all mice have a nocturnal
or a crepuscular feeding pattern most of
their eating or food intake is done in
the early part of the night
this can be a problem because the
typical working pattern of a scientist
is
diurnal their work in the lab tends to
be done during the day
when mice are usually sleepy and not so
hungry so if a scientist wants to be in
the lab testing mice from nine to five
they've already got a potential
motivation problem on their hands
of course it's a solvable problem
because maybe you have a scientist who's
a night owl
or maybe you're keeping your mice on a
reverse light cycle which means that
their day becomes our night
and in these cases then the scientists
working hours and the mouse's
working hours go inside
but even in this case you can't get
around the fact that mice have tiny
little stocks
they get satiated very quickly
a mouse will eat something like four
grams of food per day
but if it's up to them they'll spread
that out over several hours and they
usually won't eat much more than about
half a gram at any given time or within
any short period of time
so this means that even though as a
scientist you'd like ideally to be able
to run
100 trials of an operand test in each
individual session
the mouse simply isn't interested in
working for food for that long
and here's what that can look like when
an animal
is not interested in working for food in
your apparatus
hmm
it appears that the video is not showing
up
um technical difficulties let me take a
second
in case the video issue doesn't resolve
i will describe what we're seeing
we see him as so the videos will not
play so we've got a mouse inside of
a team ace a standard hand run teammates
one that a mouse will be carried into
and then tested
and his teammates has a left arm and a
right arm that contain bowls of food
what we see at the beginning of the clip
is the mouse on task
solving the problem the mouse walks
right to the back of the t-arm into the
right arm
and fetches food from one of the bowls
correct answer great
but in the second part of the clip we
see her now start wandering around the
apparatus she wanders over to the other
bowl puts her paws upon it doesn't even
look inside
she goes back to the start of the
apparatus then goes
back into the right choice arm and she's
rearing up a lot on the sides of the
apparatus
she's not even looking for food so it
seems that she's exploring the apparatus
at this point
for an entirely different purpose and
the danger is that if we're not
attentive to this
then when we see a mouse wandering into
one of the choice arms
and maybe she's just exploring maybe
she's not trying to solve our clever
puzzle that we've set up for her
we can mistake that for a mouse who is
actually trying to solve the puzzle
and if she gets the wrong answer then we
might be like to think that it's because
she has poor learning or poor memory
capacity
when in fact maybe it's just that
motivation is lacking at this particular
moment
so as i mentioned before a potential
solution to this is to let animals
work only when they're motivated to work
once again this is obviously a recurring
theme
what you're doing here is giving the
animal control
and if the test apparatus is part of the
animal's home cage or if it's attached
to the animal's home cage
that means they're free to go in and to
be tested when they're motivated to do
so
and for a mouse this will usually mean
at night and in short bursts
i think back again to that yorkie's
dodson law
we're avoiding the rightmost side of
that
solid line there the side where the
stress of handling and of aversive
testing becomes too great
and starts to starts to to degrade
performance
but we're also avoiding the zone of low
arousal on the left side
because that can also lead to low
performance and we're doing that by not
testing animals when we've just woken
them up in the middle of the day
or when they're otherwise in a period of
low activity
we're letting them decide to take the
test only when they're hungry and when
they're ready to do so
when they're moderately aroused
somewhere near the center of that graph
where they might be able to perform at a
peak level
and i have a video that i would like to
show you
that shows what that looks like what
testing an animal in an automated team
is as you see pictured there can look
like
and what you see at first is the animal
standing in the
main chamber what's like what's uh
labeled as test side here
and the animal is walking around doing
basically the same thing that we saw
in the first video which is off task
behavior
walking around smelling things exploring
then she goes into the start arm
of the teammates and actually gives a
response what's great about this is that
in this context it's entirely fine that
she's performing off-cast behavior
because that off-task behavior takes
place in the home page itself and it
doesn't take place in the maze that's
attached to the home cage
so that means there's much less danger
that we'll mistake off task behavior for
on task behavior
and end up with basically jumped data we
won't mistake a mouse
who's exploring the apparatus for one
who's actually trying to solve the
puzzle and get a reward
now there's some interesting results
from
a study that used an automated apparatus
the same one in that diagram there the
automated teammates
to study the effects of motivation and
satiation on performance in a spatial
discrimination task
this was done by brianna gaskill and she
trained mice in this apparatus using
three different reward sizes
either one two or four pellets
and what she found was that mice showed
better overall performance
in the long run if she trained them
using small rather than large rewards
and that's exactly what she predicted
because
mice become satiated very rapidly if
they're given large pieces of food for
each correct response
and then they lose motivation to answer
correctly on the next trial
she also found that performance was much
less variable with small rewards
the mice who were trained with small
rewards got very good overall scores
in every successive block of 10 trials
that they performed
but for the mice trained with larger
rewards there were some blocks of 10
trials where they were really on task
and they had excellent scores
and there were other blocks of 10 trials
where they seemed to be totally off and
their performance was terrible
and that's a symptom of that fluctuating
motivation
of working really hard when you're
hungry and then not working so hard
i actually found something pretty
similar in some of my own work so
over the past few years i've been
working on building an automated
home cage apparatus to regulate and to
monitor access to drinking water
we built these drinker units and
installed them in the walls
of mouse home cages and the drinkers are
equipped with rfid readers
that detect and identify individual mice
when they stick their heads in to lift
the spout
and that's monitored and it's logged by
a computer program that then triggers a
pump to push out some water to the mouse
when the mouse comes to drink the
drinkers also have leds of different
colors built into them you can see a
blue and a green one here
and we can use these for learning
experiments we can use the lights to cue
the mice to tell them when water is
available
or where water is available and when
it's not
so i did an experiment where i trained
mice to perform a visual discrimination
they had two drinkers in their home cage
and there were three mice in the cage
and each mouse was assigned a different
color of led
here for example one mouse is assigned
to the green light that's at the top
left of every drinker in the cage and
another is assigned to the blue light at
the bottom left of every drinker in the
cage and so on
and at any given time each mouse had a
light on at one drinker
but not at the other drinker and they
needed to learn to go to the drinker
with the light on to get water
and i was able to get mice to perform
this task quite well
by training them in three stages of
increasing difficulty
so that by the last stage they were able
to go to the correct drinker
by paying attention to their specific
light light of the right color
while ignoring the lights of the other
colors that were assigned to their cage
mates
and since the mice approach the drinkers
at irregular intervals whenever they
choose in this kind of
voluntary setup i was able to use the
use data from this experiment to show
that one of the main determinants of how
likely a mouse was to choose the correct
drinker the one with the light on
was how thirsty that mouse was how long
has it been since this mouse has last
had a dream
if a mouse had last had a drink in the
last minute then that mass performed at
basically chance levels
50 50 getting it right or getting it
wrong but the longer it had been
since she had a drink the better that
mouse performance was
again presumably because the more
thirsty you are the higher is your
motivation to get the right answer
okay so to do a little brief recap
we're using automated home page offering
tasks because we want to make testing
less aversive
and because we want to maintain
motivation
and we've already seen some data that
shows that each of these components
making it less aversive maintaining
motivation can improve performance on
cognitive tasks in isolation
but does the automated testing itself
work does it improve cognitive
performance
well the answer does seem to be yes
here's a comparison of
overall performance by my by mice in a
team a's alternation task
so this is a task where the mice are
rewarded for giving the opposite
of whatever their last response was and
this was run
in a standard hand-run version and in an
automated homecage version
the same one that you've seen diagrams
of before it turned out the mice tested
in the
automated gauge performed significantly
better than mice tested in the standard
way
and the automated maze helped either by
maintaining motivation
or by reducing how aversive this test is
or maybe some of both
and again we might see this as an animal
who has control over their testing
schedule
and the animals choosing to work when
they're at that optimal level of
moderate arousal
they're not sleepy and they're not in
distress and so
automated testing can boost performance
but there's a potentially more
important set of questions does
automated testing make the data
better or higher quality is it more
consistent
does it more accurately measure what we
think it measures or what we hope it
measures
and is it more relevant to the human
patients that the animals are being used
as models of
i think some of these questions
especially towards the end we don't
quite have answers to yet but here are
some things that we do know
this is a table that shows the main
results from a big study
an international multi-laboratory study
where a group of collaborators asked
whether they could replicate the same
results
in different labs and they were
specifically looking for differences
between mice of different genetic
strains
and out of five tests that they
performed they found genotype by
environment interactions in four of
these tests
these are shown by the red box here
remember what the genotype by
environment interaction means
is that for these four tests different
labs gave
different answers some labs found
differences between genetic strains that
other labs did not
interestingly there was one test that
didn't show a genotype by environment
interaction
one test where everyone got the same as
and that was preference for drinking
and all that also happens to be the only
test in this
entire paper that's run in the home cage
all of the other tests were tests where
the experimenters handled the mice
and placed them in some sort of
apparatus there was actually a similar
multi-lab study that was run later on
using only automated home cage tests
they use an approach is called the
intellicage and they found consistent
results the same strain differences
in all the labs on all of their outcome
measures and these authors pointed
specifically to
not handling the animals as one of the
factors that was likely responsible for
this
now as to the question of whether
automated tests
are not just more consistent but more
accurately measure what we want them to
measure
i do wonder whether some of the strain
differences
in learning or memory that are reported
in the literature
might sometimes actually be artifacts of
other kinds of strain differences
here's what i mean for example let's say
one strand
consistently does better than another
genetic strain on
a handrail test of memory is it because
that first test
truly has a better memory or is it maybe
for example because that strain is
less fearful and so is less impacted by
an aversive test environment this is
something that i actually like to test
in the near future what i'd like to do
is to
choose a type of test and a group of
strains of mice where the literature
says we should expect some pretty clear
strain differences
and ideally this would be a group of
strains that's also known to differ in
how they react to abusive handling in
novel environments
and then i'd like to run these animals
through hand-run and automated versions
of the exact same test
which i don't think anyone has done in a
multi-strain study yet
now what i predict is that the hand run
test will reveal some strain differences
for example in this mock-up graph the
difference that strain a outperforms
strain b
but i also predict that these
differences might not be present in the
automated test
and that would actually provide some
some i think compelling and direct
evidence that it's specifically the way
that the test is run
that is creating these strain
differences and in the longer term i
think a potential extent
extension of this project would be to
run it again as a multi-lab study and
directly compare
automated and hand-drawn versions of the
exact same test to see whether the
automated version is again
more easily replicated
now with the brief time that i have left
i want to show you that
using an operant apparatus inside of a
mice of a mouse's home cage has
other applications than just scientific
data collection you could also use it
for some veterinary applications like
routine health monitoring
so here's an example from our lab of an
apparatus that we nicknamed mouse
monitor
there's a plexiglass tube that's
attached to a hole in the wall of this
mouse gauge
when mice enter the tube they're
detected and they're identified by an
rfid reader
that then triggers release of a food
pellet so going into the tube
is how they forage and the tube is
mounted on a scale
so besides getting foraging data from
the mice a couple hundred times a day
whenever they go into the tube
we also get dozens and dozens of
different body weight readings for each
mouse
on each day and that lets us see some
pretty subtle effects like
like the fact that mice actually
gradually change in body weight
throughout the day
they lose up to about a gram during
daylight hours when they're mostly
sleeping
the idea behind using this apparatus for
this project was to test it out as a way
of
monitoring of routine health monitoring
in animals
a way of identifying sick animals early
one other thing that motivates this
project is that there was an
epidemiological study
published a few years ago that looked at
all
the morbidities reported in a large
mouse research facility
and out of all the morbidities that
happened the most common one
was caretakers just finding amounts dead
before they ever knew that anything was
wrong with the mouse
finding mice dead was more common than
finding the other most common problems
like ulcerative dermatitis
or fight wounds and so if we can make an
automated surveillance system that can
flag animals when they fall sick before
it's too late
then that could help a lot in the future
in terms of either getting animals
treated or humanely euthanized before
they spontaneously die and it turns out
that this apparatus can detect illness
in mice
well before a human observer can some of
the mice in our project got an injection
of lps
which induces sickness behavior and the
difference between these mice
and the control mice who are not sick
could be detected behaviorally
by this apparatus within two to four
hours after the injection
and it manifested in the form of reduced
feeding behavior
now in contrast to this human caretakers
who were physically examining the mice
could not tell the difference between
the sick and the
healthy mice on the morning after the
injection nor on the afternoon after the
injection 24 hours later
so that's an example of how tapping into
foraging motivation of lab animals
using this sort of home cage foraging
apparatus can let us collect some
essential data on their health for other
purposes and research
to finish i'd like to touch on one more
thing
i focused so far in this talk mainly on
how taking the operand apparatus and
bringing it into the home cage
lets us get rid of all the aversive
aspects of a handwritten test
the things that mice don't like about
them but i think we can go further than
that
if we design the tasks right we can make
it so that mice don't just
not dislike them we can make it so that
the mice actually liked the tasks
which means that we'd be taking what's
normally a bad testing experience
and turning it into something that
animals actually want to do
and we do this by turning it into
something that they have control over
and that's a form of enrichment
that we would add to their home
environments
now how do we know whether experimental
animals really like a task
how do we know that they're doing it
because they like it and not
just because that's how we set up
environment their environment because we
basically bribed them by telling them
you have to do this to get
food every day well here's a nice
example from the literature right
it gets pretty clear that the animals
like the task
there's a video that goes with this and
i would really encourage you to look up
this
um this paper and look at the videos in
the
supplementary materials because they're
really worth a look this is work by
julie mcgrath
who trained dozens of individual wild
birds on a visual discrimination task
rather she put the apparatus in the
forest and the birds just started
coming to it they volunteered to train
themselves and the video in question
is one of a bird who's clearly mastered
checking on whichever
key on this apparatus displays a red
light in exchange for some meal worms
and since these are wild animals who are
engaged with an opera dapparatus
in their native environment i think it's
definitely clear that it's not the case
that they're somehow forced into
into performing this task because there
are other places they can get food and
they don't really even have to come near
this box if they're not interested
and there's another phenomenon that
suggests that captive animals also like
to work
it's called contra free loading and it's
been observed repeatedly in many
different species
contra freeloading is when animals
prefer to work to get food instead of
getting that same food for free
for example you might have a bowl of
free food beside a lever
and if the animal pulls that lever that
dispenses the same food
that is available in the bowl right
beside it and animals will pull that
lever
an example of this that i really like is
one that comes from
so pigs pigs in this study were exposed
to two types of pen
one where it was easy to get food and
one where it was difficult to get food
the first pen had straw on the floor and
food in a trough
very easy to get the second one also had
straw on the floor and had the same type
of food but it was scattered inside the
straw
which meant the food was harder to get
because the pigs had to root through the
straw with their noses to find it
and when they were later tested as to
which environment they prefer to spend
time in
the pigs actually chose the environment
where they had to work for food
to find that food in the straw the
reason that i like this specific
experiment
is because it's one where the task that
the pigs have to perform
to get that food is a normal part of
their repetitive behavior
as pigs pigs are intrinsically motivated
to root
in the substrate for food when they're
hungry so it makes a lot of sense that a
pig would like this type of work
and it illustrates how using what the
animal is naturally designed to do
is a huge part of making a successful
enrichment and making a successful
operant task
in addition to tapping into the animal's
natural foraging repertoire
i think something else we should
consider when designing operant
cognitive
tasks in the home cage is whether these
tasks are cognitively stimulating
to the animals because that could make
them extra enriching
there's an interesting review paper on
this topic on
how we can make cognitive tasks
interesting to animals
and in this paper the authors propose
that a crucial dimension
that determines how an animal feels
about a task is how challenging that
task is
and whether or not the degree of
challenge is well matched to the
animal's degree of skill
if task is too easy the animals may
become bored with it
if it's too difficult they may become
frustrated
but if a task is well matched to the
level of skill
then the authors suggest that if these
animals are anything like humans
they might experience what in psychology
is called a state of flow
flow is this rewarding highly engaged
state of mind that i think locally we
could call
being in the zone and i think i
experience flow sometimes
as an example when i'm writing computer
code or when i'm climbing
at the climbing wall and in both cases
it happens when that level of challenge
is just right when i just about got it
and i really need to just give the task
my full attention and effort to succeed
and the outside world kind of
loses focus and fades away because i'm
fully concentrated
and that's a really rewarding
pleasurable state i think if it's
something that we can possibly let
animals experience when they're in our
care
then that would be a great target to
strive for
and that might mean making operand tasks
in the home cage progressively more
difficult
as the animals gain incompetence to keep
that match between competence and skill
and that is a good fit with how some
complex tasks have to be taught anyway
they have to be taught in stages
and so i think that by keeping these
design principles in mind we can come up
with the right tasks that animals will
end up
enjoying and they'll want to engage with
so to summarize i hope i've shown you
that there's potential in designing
automated versions of tests for
laboratory animals
and integrating these tests into their
home environments
that there's potential to make the lives
of the animals better by giving them
back some measure of control
giving them the option to avoid aversive
situations the
option to participate in our experiments
only when they want to
and even the options to seek out intense
positive experience
experiences potentially that's what true
environmental enrichment is
and there's potential in doing this to
improve the quality of the science as
well
potential to get more consistent results
that can be replicated between labs
and hopefully to get more meaningful
results because we start treating
animals like we treat human patients
which means giving them control and
placing priority on their well-being
and i think and i hope that in the long
run this can lead to improved welfare
for the lab animals
and to improved outcomes for human
patients
so to finish i would like to thank all
of my collaborators listed here who
worked with me on the projects that i've
mentioned in this talk
thanks to lab roots for giving me the
opportunity to speak today thanks to
alexis for
moderating and thanks to everyone for
watching
thank you